all right welcome to Hannity all right
buckle up tonight I have a special
message for Jim Comey now for nearly two
years the United States of America we
have somehow managed to survive without
the dedicated stewardship of our
righteous moral Savior the ever so
virtuous and honorable James Comey now
thankfully he's back and telling all of
us you know where the stupid smelly
Walmart shoppers of America and of
course his colleague and friend Peter
struck that's how he refers to us he's
now telling us how to behave as the mole
of witch-hunt nears its conclusion I
will get to that we're going to show you
what the indignant totally disgraced
fired FBI director had to say and we're
going to remind you of all about James
Comey and why the President did the
country a favor by firing him all right
but first we'll get to that in a minute
it's time for our ongoing Hannity watch
on the radical socialist Democratic 2020
candidates we start tonight with really
more bizarre behavior from robert
Francis Bayes Oh bozo O'Rourke now no
countertop apparently our table is safe
in America well why Robert Frances seems
to force his way into every restaurant
every diner in the great state of Iowa
and it appears that he's just fallen in
love with these elevated surfaces as the
moves whatever he does now cover your
food cover your drinks because yeah bado
is coming to a town near you
and apparently stomping all over where
you actually eat now perhaps you're just
trying to spread the magical healing
powers what we told you last night of
eating dirt which he did Apple a lot of
it after he lost the Ted Cruz and went
to New Mexico and he thinks they have
supernatural powers and by the way he
acts even brought some home for his
family to eat what a generous gift
now of course his behavior on the
campaign trail it pales in comparison to
his extreme and nutty ideas take for
example we now know that bait oh well
his all-out war against border walls not
only is he against the president's plan
for expanding border security but he
also wants to
existing border walls so our borders
then would be completely wide open and
because according to bado
there are no problems none in our
southern border take a look you're not
need any walls thirty billion dollars
two thousand miles long thirty feet high
that will not be built on the
international boundary line which is a
centerline of the Rio Grande River that
wall will be built well into the
interior on someone's ranch someone
else's farm someone else's home you and
I will be forced to take their property
to solve a problem that we do not have
so all the human trafficking that we've
chronicled even young girls into
prostitution all the drug trafficking
violent gangs cartels the two-percent
not that ninety-eight percent the three
hundred Americans killed every week from
heroin ninety percent crosses that
border I guess none of that seems to
matter to robert francis O'Rourke and I
guess the angel moms and dads who we've
interviewed who have lost their family
members and their children from heroin
overdoses
I guess he isn't pay attention to them
maybe he needs a long conversation with
them because that crosses our southern
border and I guess none of this seems to
matter or maybe he's just living in an
alternative reality from ingesting too
much dirt either way he's in good
company
within his own party for example fellow
Democratic congresswoman Alexandria
Castillo Cortez now the leader pushing
the bizarre far-left radical ideas these
are not based in reality she wants to
ban all air travel get rid of the
combustion engine and all oil and gas in
ten years and cows because of ana
pending a cop a pop apocalypse she
actually thinks the world is gonna end
in 12 years but that didn't stop her
from touring this massive eight billion
dollar expansion of LaGuardia Airport in
New York City no that's her district
isn't that the very thing she wants to
ban and here she is cheering on the
expansion of that Airport right in our
home city so of course this is an
airport she utilizes we now know an
awful lot now you can take Amtrak the
Acela train between New York and DC but
she prefers to travel via Delta the
shuttle now it's a do as I say not as I
do it's kind of like the socialist way
right congresswoman how do you watch the
channel so much now this kind of rampant
hypocrisy doesn't matter the mainstream
media at all look at Time magazine just
featured her on its cover calling her
quote the Phenom now more on the radical
far-left socialist Democratic Party and
their best friends in the media in just
a minute also tonight the great one Mark
Levin will be with us and the ever so
brilliant Victor Davis Hanson all right
but first we do turn to some good news
before we get to our top story out of
Syria now remember in 2015 then
candidate Donald Trump remember he made
this promise let's take a look
they want to go after our civilians they
want to kill not only our civilians all
over the world and it's going to be
stopped it's going to be stopped
somebody criticized me the other day
because they asked me what I do and I
said I'm gonna bomb the that of them
it's true I don't care they've got to be
stopped very different politician
promises made and a lot of promises kept
now those insane rules of engagement
from the Obama era were lifted president
Trump has unleashed American airpower
bombing Isis over and over and over
again and with the help of that air
cover the us-backed Syrian forces just
cleared what is the final strip of land
once held by Isis fighters the one they
took over originally tens of thousands
of radical jihadists have surrendered
many other thousands have been killed
the so-called Caliphate is no more but
of course the struggle against radical
Islamic extremism and those sympathetic
to Isis we must forever remain vigilant
by the way the president today
recognized Golan Heights as Israel
territory again he was the only
president so many promised Jerusalem's
their rightful capital he made it happen
well we shift gears we turn our
attention to Hannity watch on Muller's
witch-hunt and this is our top story
tonight the seemingly never-ending probe
appears to be in its final stage
president wants molars full report
released to the public
by the way he doesn't decide that but he
wants everyone
everywhere to see it with their own eyes
that after nine months by the way of
investigations from Comey and his FBI
that was before Mahler and then nearly
700 days of investigations from Muller
well we know there's no evidence of any
Trump Russia collusion none zero nothing
remember we learned last week Lisa page
Peter struck testified that the FBI's
nine-month investigation before the
appointment of Muller came up empty they
had nothing the House the Senate
investigations they also came up empty
nothing look at this
NBC News is panicking they're worried
they recently ran a report entitled
quote you may be disappointed by the
Muller report in other words the
conspiracy theories that their network
has been peddling for two-plus years
might be about to be confronted with
truth and meanwhile the ever virtuous
savior of America morality he's back and
he's telling you exactly what you need
to think about the impending Special
Counsel report in an op-ed in The New
York Times the always sanctimonious
self-righteous Jim Comey writing that
he's not rooting for President Trump to
be guilty of a crime instead he's quote
rooting for a demonstration to the world
that the United States justice system
works really well Jim Comey I don't
believe a single word you say time now
for a Hannity history lesson on James
Comey and his role in all of this he is
the root of almost everything here James
Comey well he was the one who totally
mishandled and helped rig the Clinton
investigation he's the one that allowed
Obama's attorney general Loretta Lynch
remember to dictate how his agency was
conducting the investigation
or should I say matter which he allowed
her to say when he knew it was supposed
to be an investigation he was leading it
Jim Comey the one who oversaw Clinton's
exoneration letter of May of 2016
three months before the investigation
ended and three months before Hillary
Clinton other key witnesses were ever
even interviewed what I call the
exoneration before investigation and by
the way it was he who allowed two other
people in the room with Hillary
when she's being interrogated supposedly
remember he's the one that signed off on
changing that all-important language in
that letter and the exoneration letter
gross negligence was taken out that
would be the criminal statute and the
words extreme carelessness put in and
then of course they had the new standard
intent that they just made up in the law
which is not all at the direction of
Obama's DOJ which we learned last week
Yeah right in Loretta Lynch's office
she's taking control of all of this
according to Paige instruct and remember
Jim Comey he's the one that lied about
all of this on Capitol Hill when he
testified that he didn't write the
exoneration letter before interviewing
Clinton that was a lie he's the one who
allowed rampant anti-trump bias to
fester among his top officials including
Paige struck McCabe and so many more
remember it was Jim Comey who allowed
the person that called Trump supporter
his us smelly Walmart people and vowed
to stop Trump from becoming president
well he let him lead the investigation
into the Trump campaign and by the way
he's the guy that also interviewed
Hillary and by the way it was Jim Comey
who purposely leaked sensitive
confidential government memos about the
president after he was unceremoniously
well fired and he did it for the very
purposes of ensuring that a Special
Counsel investigation happened after his
own nine-month investigation got nothing
and that his good friend Robert Muller
was appointed to lead the witch-hunt
even though again they had found nothing
you may remember this i asked president
tweeted on friday after I got fired that
I better hope there's not tapes I woke
up in the middle of the night on Monday
night because it didn't dawn on me
originally that there might be
corroboration for our conversation there
might be a tape and my judgment was I
needed to get that out into the public
square and so I asked a friend of mine
to share the content of the memo with a
reporter didn't do it myself for a
variety of reasons but I asked him to
because I thought that might prompt the
appointment of a special counsel
Jim Comey we also signed the first FISA
application this is in October 2016 in
other words it was Jim Comey who
clearly we now know committed fraud with
his signature before a FISA Court judge
what did he used the bulk of information
Nunez Grassley Graham memo tells us was
Hillary Clinton's bought and paid for
dirty Russian dossier it was call me
whom fact who hid the fact that the
dossiers contents small little detail
Hillary paid for it but they didn't tell
the FISA Court big bold letter she paid
for it that this was a partisan document
unverified uncorroborated and that would
be called to my world fraud by omission
small oversight mr. Comey was Jim Comey
who signed off on that document that was
completely think about this unverifiable
how do we know it's unverifiable because
it's author Christopher steel testified
in an interrogatory in Great Britain he
had no idea if any of that dossier was
true and we now know most of it is
totally debunked but that's what they
presented to the FISA Court judge
now I thought if I remember correctly a
FISA application can only be a pain if a
career law enforcement official swears
that the information is true and correct
or else there'll be serious consequences
where did I learn that from Oh rod
Rosenstein take a look FISA application
is actually a warrant just like a search
warrant in order to get a FISA search
warrant you need an affidavit signed by
a career federal law enforcement officer
who swears that the information in the
affidavit is true and correct to the
best of his knowledge and belief and
that's the way we operate and if that's
wrong sometimes it is if you find out
there's anything incorrect in there that
person is gonna face consequences Jim
Comey put a signature swearing that to
the best of his knowledge it's true and
accurate
well even its own author doesn't believe
that and by the way now he's going to
lecture us on how we the American people
need to judge the Muller report that he
set up none of this would have happened
none of it except Jim Comey allowed his
personal ambition his animus his hatred
of Donald Trump get in the way how do
you sign off on a warrant
that's impossible to verify how do you
do that
you know when Steele said you can't
verify he can't verify his own we're
only 50-50 chance of it's true how do
you hide from a judge
Hillary paid for that dossier the
opposition party paid for it and three
months after he signed that October 2016
warrant well then he went to Trump Tower
in January 2017 and told then
president-elect Trump that the dossier
exists
it's unverified and it's salacious the
opposite of what he would have signed
off on in October in other words based
on the garbage being truthful three
months earlier what he swore to that is
called fraud that is called lying that
is called a fraud that also think about
this it denied one of our fellow
citizens their constitutional right that
would be Carter page fraud that the
media because we know they leaked the
dossier is a coffin corn and Washington
Post so that was fraud leaked before the
American people to influence the
election with Russian lies fraud that
was used to elect the candidate that he
and others obviously preferred flawed
fraud then to bludgeon a duly elected
president to undo the election because
he knew better because he hated Trump
just like his disciples struck in Page
in other words first they rigged an
investigation by the way mr. Comey do
you think if I deleted subpoenaed emails
and I asked him wash my hard drive and
had somebody bust up my devices you
think I'd get away with that I don't
think so but they cleared Hillary of all
charges they rigged that investigation
now you he thought that he knew better
than you we the American people and to
this day collé me thinks he's an
American super Patriot he's not this has
nothing to do by the way with
rank-and-file FBI people Jim Comey
tainted what is the greatest law
enforcement agency in the world he did
that thanks to his horrible leadership
his actions and decisions as the
director of the FBI we now have serious
doubts in this country as to whether or
not equal justice under the law still
exists because of what he and a
with the highest levels of government
did in this case